You've drawn your levels. You've done
your analysis. So, why does the market
still blow right through them?
Support, resistance, V up, Fibonacci,
moving averages. Traders use dozens of
tools to find the same thing, a level
that holds. But most of the time, it
doesn't. And nobody talks about why.
Because a level on the chart is just a
line. What makes it real is the
liquidity sitting behind it. Heat maps
and level two data show you exactly
where the big money is stacked at before
price even get there.
And if you are new to heat maps, we've
already got a full setup and
walk-through guide on this channel. Go
check that out first.
The best traders aren't predicting
moves. They are confirming them. One
extra layer of data can turn a 50/50
guess into a high probability setup.
In this video, you will see exactly how
to combine heat maps with the levels you
are already trading and start seeing the
market the way institutions do.
A heat map
isn't a strategy on its own. It's the
confirmation layer that makes your
existing strategy sharper. Combine it
with price action, level two data, the
levels you are already trading, and
suddenly, you are not guessing where the
market might react. You know where the
liquidity is. You see the sweeps coming.
You enter with conviction, not hope.
That extra layer of confidence, that's
what separates a decent setup from a
high-probability one.
I'm going to
draw this level
and the next one, this level. These are
two levels inside of the area identified
previously. I mentioned that this was
the 30-minute chart. Now switch to the
faster chart. In this case, it's the
30-second chart.
And we immediately see something.
This is the level I drew as the second
one. This is the line I drew previously.
I can obviously make it wider.
And when I switch back to the 30-minute
chart,
it was this peak, this swing high.
And the next one is another white, which
I'm going to make wider as well. And the
blue one is the zone.
Now let's switch back to the heat map,
and you see that this was the zone,
and these were the levels.
There was something There was something
happening at this level. Remember, when
you press the control key,
then you get the information about the
waiting orders at that levels. 395
orders waiting at that level.
And this
is another level. I'm talking about this
orange orange-ish uh
>> [music]
>> area, zone, level actually, with
waiting limit orders. And imagine
Actually, not imagine. And look at this
reaction, this wonderful reaction. I'm
going to
make this line thinner again, so that it
does not disturb us, like so, width of
two. And check this out. The price moved
very aggressively
during these
during this range did not react to this
waiting
of 390 orders, actually 440 orders at
the moment of approaching the area.
There was a small reaction here, but the
market continued upwards. And these 261
waiting limit orders, waiting sell
orders because the price approached the
area from below. So, obviously, these
200 and
65 orders were waiting sell orders. When
the price approaches the level from
below, then above it's
it's a zone with the sell orders.
And the price approached that level, and
there was the reaction.
So, this is how you can, so to say,
get more sure that the level you draw
can be the reaction one, not just
something you can draw, I don't know, 10
levels a set, 50 levels at the chart.
Which one will be the reactive one?
There was actually a tick-perfect
reaction here at this level. You see
that? It's actually tick-perfect, but
the important thing is that the heat map
served in this case as the confirmation.
And confirmed that the reaction here
made sense. How you could have handled
that? Obviously, the easiest way, which
I personally like, is waiting for the
shift in the market structure, change of
character,
when price created this significant
swing low.
It's obviously very significant swing
low because
there's a wick, there's a pin bar, which
some traders consider as a reversal, or
in this case in this case continuation
continuation
pattern, but price broke through here
for instance. And actually you can see
that the price returned back to this
area.
And again, see how this situation
happened here. This is exactly the This
is in fact the second example I was
going to talk about today. And it
happened here.
The zone the waiting sell orders started
to build here.
Because
the market reacted here, created this
very interesting pivot candle with a
very tiny body and wicks above and
below. These candles within a trend are
very important ones such as this one.
But let's stick back to the heat map
theory and price broke through, created
here this pivot candle, broke through,
started to return to this area. And here
you can see that they started building a
wall kind of
resistance level.
All of the sudden because they broke
through, there was nothing nothing
nothing. They started adding to the
position here. This is the majority of
the waiting limit
sell orders and there was this reaction.
So you could have joined this movement.
It's important to understand that the
heat map
as such is
oriented at the fastest scalping.
Usually at the S&P 500 ES, you open the
trade with a stop loss of let's say
three ticks, four ticks, you know, one
point. And [music] you aim at two to one
or 3:1. So, when you start that sink,
this
There was nothing nothing nothing. They
started building the zone. They started
adding to position because the color of
the level is getting more and more
yellow. Now it's the orange-ish level
with the most orders. I can press again
the control key at my keyboard
>> [music]
>> and there were
waiting limit orders. And there was this
reaction. So, you could have actually
opened a short position up on the
closing of the candle. They actually
revisited the area. You see that?
You see the middle of the range created
by the heat map and they revisited the
area just to shake out the
uh hesitating traders, you know? They
could have opened the position here at
the closing of this red inverted pin bar
with a stop loss here aiming at 2:1,
which is approximately here. But there
was some hesitation. There was some
pullback against the position. So, they
were actually
uh at zero profit and loss. Then they
got into the loss. Some of them could
have actually leave the position, which
was wrong because in fact, we see here a
confirmation of the idea to continue.
I'm talking about this tiny
rectangle up. And as soon as they
revisited the area, they moved downwards
quite significantly.
And uh if you opened the position here,
as said, with a stop loss above the
candle, then 2:1 is approximately here.
You can
close the trade here and actually
continue.
And the third example is actually at the
same chart without moving anywhere.
I don't know whether I have a proper
setting at this chart. I don't want
candles to transform into 060. That's
okay. I will increase it even to 80.
Now, look at this. They created this
low. I'm talking about this
uh swing low, and then they started
moving upwards. Now, we know actually to
retest the area, the breakout uh our
break through area.
They created
this candle.
And after this candle, they started
building this zone. I'm talking about
the this
zone. So, this is the third approach how
you can engage heat map into your
trading. When you expect a reaction, I
don't know what was there, but it
doesn't matter. I can actually uh decode
the situation at the chart. They created
a candle and started building the wall
below the price.
Wall below the price means means
obviously support, and support uh
waiting limit buy orders. So, you see
that they started to build the wall.
I will zoom in so that we see it in a
more detail, and uh check this out. They
visited the area with this candle. They
visited the area again with this candle,
and then they continued to the area we
identified before. So, this is also
confirmation of something uh uh when
something's happening at the chart. They
created this swing high. They broke
through. Draw it like here. This is the
swing high.
Then, they actually
went back to the area
with this movement.
Yeah, they revisited it from above.
And it was supported by
heat map because they started adding to
position. All of the sudden there was an
interest to
uh
to
be the part of the movement up to
uh open
long positions and continue upwards. And
there was then there was this reaction.
So, we could have it actually scalped
here or you could have opened the long
position here. Both is possible because
I mentioned these are super fast and
super short scalps. These are 30-second
candles. This is a very fast time frame.
And actually, these are trades taking 2
minutes, 3 minutes, 5 minutes, and so.
So, this is a very fast development.
Now, I moved forwards a little and I
will show you another phenomenon called
liquidity sweep, which is a
technique or the event based on the
smart money concept, but not
necessarily. It's very It's a very
logical It's a very logical content.
Uh look at this.
Look at this candle, which created this
swing high. There was this
area of waiting limit sell orders.
They visited the area and there was this
reaction. So, obviously, you could have
opened short position here. But let's
move on.
They started adding to position. You
see? Because they expected or they hoped
the market to revisit the area and join
the uptrend.
>> [music]
>> It was actually here. See, there are
yellowish areas and orangeish areas. The
more orange the color, I will switch
back to the
pointer and check this out.
Here, we have uh
waiting orders, 174 waiting orders. Here
we have 150, here we have 141
and they [music] revisited the previous
swing high by this candle. But, what
happened?
They actually
moved above the candle by three ticks
and created this swing high.
And this candle, actually, because it's
a negative candle, confirmed the
reaction. They
They visited the area, the zone, or
actually in this case it's one
one tick area, so the level, and then
they started moving downwards.
They simply decided to take out the
liquidity, sweep it. It's a liquidity
sweep. Sweep the liquidity, revisit by
revisiting the area, which was actually
confirmed by this
heat map row by the yellow orange
rectangle. And from now on they started
moving downwards. And if you zoom out a
little, I will get rid of the drawings,
you see that this could have been a very
very nice trade. With the area, this is
the original blue area with these two
lines, they revisited them again.
So, some areas like reacting a lot. For
example, here, this is the case I
described before. They visited the area,
the blue range from above with this red
candle, and then they built this waiting
these waiting limit buy orders. They
purchased, they closed as a doji candle,
and then they took off the liquidity.
So, again, this entire situation at the
chart makes a lot of sense, but imagine
without heat map.
Without heat map, it looks like this.
So, yes, it makes sense. You see that
this was a tick perfect reaction that
they revisited the area of the previous
swing lows. Those were two swing lows
which I showed at the very beginning of
this continuation,
and this was the reaction. But, if you
engage heat map, then you
get an additional piece of the
confirmation. An additional
uh
security, a kind of
uh you are more sure that something is
happening or is about to happen. Is
happening, it's this case, because they
visited the area, started building it,
started building the wall of the waiting
limit buy orders, or what is about to
happen is here. They created this swing
high, but there was still waiting zone,
you know? And I emphasized at the very
beginning that everything should make
sense, because, for example, check this
area. Does it make any sense?
Yes and no, because those who were going
to short could have placed the waiting
limit sell orders
in advance, you know?
They could have expected that the market
may turn here, because basically this is
a
order block. This candle is a red one,
but it's a positive candle.
It's another block.
So, you see that these basically
uh waiting limit sell orders make sense.
But, this one makes even more sense,
because they, as said, revisited it
without creating double double top.
They took out liquidity, and they moved
downwards.
And the final example how you can engage
heat map into your trading is this
situation.
I'm going to talk about this level with
waiting limit sell orders, because the
price approached the level from below.
So, this is a resistance waiting limit
sell orders. But, check this out.
The price came to this level and broke
through
as if there
was nothing at all. Price broke through,
and
the market participants somehow started
buying this wall below the price. So,
the
previous
resistant resistance turned into
support.
And when the price came back to the
level, you see it's still the same
level. It's still this price level.
And when the price revisited this broken
level, previously
waiting limit sell orders, which turned
after the breakout, they turned into
waiting limit buy orders. So, you pay
attention to the previously broken
levels,
which actually, after the breakout, turn
into the opposite, from resistance into
support and you see that they started
adding more and more into the position.
There were quite a few of them, but then
they got rid of it because the zone is
grayish again. Now we have some blue or
blue green colors, blue colors. Now we
have very orange color here, which
represents
a high number of the waiting limit buy
orders and again, as soon as price
started approaching the level, they
started adding to position. You see more
and more orange color and they visited
the area from above
means they came back to the support and
from this on you could have opened a
long position and basically participate
at the uptrend. If I unzoom it again,
then it looks like this. You see?
So, opening a position, let's say,
again, no reaction, no reaction. Here
was the reaction. So, it's important to
know why there is this reaction. Maybe
there's a previous
very probably very probably there's a
previous resistance or a broken support,
whatever. It makes sense here. You see
that the reactions are actually perfect,
but should make sense, otherwise you
don't know. You see a huge wall of
waiting orders, you open the position
without any reason, so to say, just
because of heat map and it can be
painful, actually. So, it's much much
better to combine it, heat map combined
with the other
uh analytical techniques and actually
trade it this way. So, there are two
approaches. You could have actually
opened very very aggressively
at this candle, which is the first
positive candle after the reaction to
this area, with a stop loss either below
the candle or below the swing low.
And if you were a little bit
conservative, then two to one is
approximately here. Again, we are still
at the 32nd
chart. So, if you open the position
here, you are
out at this candle, which is basically,
I don't know, three three and a half
minutes. Very fast trade.
So, this is how you can
engage heat map into your trading and
improve the win rate of your trades.
If this clicked for you, smash that like
button. It generally helps this channel
grow. And if you are still figuring out
how to read a heat map, drop a comment
below. Tell me where you are stuck, and
I will make sure the next video answers
it. Subscribe if you want to keep
leveling up. We drop new content every
week, and you don't want to miss what's
coming next. The market doesn't wait.
Make your move.